hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're
continuing our coverage of the second
tournament in the 2019 grand-prix series
this one's based out of Latvia the Grand
Prix series if you're not familiar it's
a four tournament series at the end of
it the top two players get a berth into
the Canada's tournament next year winner
of that tournament does go on to face
Magnus Carlsen for the world
championship
each player is assigned three
tournaments they plan so they don't play
all four they're trying to accumulate as
many points as they can in each of the
Grand Prix tournaments this is a
heads-up battle there's 16 players in
each of the tournaments and you play a
best of two series if you beat your
individual opponents then you go on to
the next round and we get into the
quarters and then eventually the semis
and the finals so best of two in round
one game number one a lot of drawls
meaning that in game number two in round
one if there's one side that gets the
victory they will move on to their next
opponent where everyone else if there's
two draws they will have some tiebreaker
game so our competitors today why it's
gonna be played by the youngster
twenty-three year old Daniel dubov
he's Russian Grandmaster very fun player
to watch if you haven't seen him he's
extremely creative goes down lines that
we don't see a lot of others go down so
fun to see him in this tournament he was
the organizers nominee so you have a
certain number of players that are in
here based on the rating and then a few
for each of the tournaments that the
organizers can can put in there just to
make sure that they have 16 competitors
for all four of the tournaments his
opponent playing the black piece is the
number eight ranked player in the world
and that is shucky or mama da da so
we'll go ahead and get into the action
starts out with Knight to f3 black
responds at Knight to f6 we see pawn c4
pawn c5 so this still could be lots of
different options as far as the opening
night here to c3 pawn d5 and then after
Knight to d5 pawn D
or would you see the night come down
here to see three the pond recaptures
and then pawn to g6 so this is the
grünfeld this is the exchange variation
as we see here and usually the exchange
just as looking at the pawns here black
doesn't always capture here on c3 the
main difference in this Grunfeld in all
the other grunt fellas we've ever
covered is it's not common that this
Knight here is here on f3 many times
you'll see the pawn push forward to e4
which is exactly what we see in this
game but the Knights still here on g1
later you'll see the knight come to e2
many times that follows the bishop here
on c4 so the knight on f3 even started
that was that the very first move that
Daniel played is extremely uncommon now
in the exchange variation if you're not
extremely familiar with it you can see
that white has a strong presence in the
center of the board so black tries to do
two things one tries to bring his pawn
here to c5 to break up that pawn
structure which he did very early the
second move that's exactly what Shakir
played and then he also wants to bring
his bishop here to g7 just put another
piece attacking the center here on d4 so
we see Bishop to g7 and then Bishop here
to b5 since the Knights gonna be not
gonna be coming here to YouTube doesn't
have to worry too much about what's
gonna happen with this bishop so decided
to go and get it outside this pawn chain
cap attack this King right here get
ready to castle on his own and Knight to
c3 Knights being pinned down right here
castle on the King side Castle on the
King side Bishop to e3 this does open up
for semi-open file if wants to bring his
rook here to b1 start to attack as well
does not want to go ahead and exchange
right now he has a great Bishop
hairy-ass control of the center of the
board he's the one that control if he
wants to open up the board state and so
you don't want to give up your bishop
pair here so early
Bishop comes down here to g4 pinning
down the Knights completely okay pushes
forward with pawn to d5 attacking the
Knights Knight decides to come down to
e5
putting another attacker on in this
knight on f3 and really need to bring
the bishop back here to e2
and that's exactly what Daniel plays
there's no other good option if there is
some exchange here you don't want to end
up recapturing with your pawn on f3 it
completely exposes your King here and
well I can just put a lot of pressure so
correctly brings his Bishop down here to
e2 and we start to see some exchange
Knight takes on f3 Bishop takes Bishop
takes here and then the Queen recaptures
on f3 now one thing you'll notice this
did do is leaves this pawn here on c3
under attack Bishop still here on g7 so
decides to come down and take the pawn
here on c3 now y can recapture this but
first he has to recognize that the rook
here on a1 is under attack so he would
like to just start out with Bishop takes
on c5 get that same pawn back now it's
discovered attack attack this Bishop
right here but then the bishop could
just freely take here on a1 so it has to
deal with that first and correctly just
plays rook to be one gets that up harm
way also attacks this pawn here on b7
place pawn to b6 and well yes this is
solidifying the pawn chain it protects
this Daniel can still take freely with
his Bishop here because if the pawn
takes then the Queen could just come
over here and capture on c3 so circular
has some options as far as how he wants
to continue he decides to bring his rook
over here to c8 he does not want to give
up his Bishop and so this is one way to
go about doing that now we still could
see in exchange on the board but instead
of that exchange we see the bishop come
down here to III Queen to d7 work over
here to a c1 just trying to control the
Queen side of the board no side really
has a strong attack right here it's
pretty even in the game this Bishop on
c3 it's not really able to do too much
all the pawns right here on light
squares and doesn't have too much of the
material involved into the game
the rook here on f8 eventually we like
to get involved still has not pushed his
central pawn here on e7 so Shakir has
done a good job of defending neither
side really has a strong attack here
pawn to f5 is where things start to
shift and black says I want to start
going for a strong attack here
and so after pawn f5 we see pawn g3 does
not want to have to worry about this
pawn coming to f4 he could eventually
bring his bishop back here to e5 putting
more pressure on this square right here
and especially with his rook here on f8
just doesn't want to have to deal with
that so decides to go and push up with
pawn g3 Bishop now comes back to f6
Bishop to f4 and then the pawn takes on
e4 and this changes quite a bit in the
game did not have to take this material
have a lot of different options as soon
as he takes this there's now an isolated
pawn here on d5 I slay pawns don't have
pawns on either side of them and later
in the game especially with a lot of the
major pieces the Queen's and the rooks
it's much more difficult to hold on to
that because you want to be attacking
all over the board but you always have
to pay attention to controlling that
pawn just in the center of the board
but you can see after the Queen takes
here Black has their own isolated pawn
here on e7 so lots of different targets
for both sides of the board to go down
now we see Queen come to f5 says yeah I
don't want to exchange right now wants
to bring his queen up here to e6 now
this forces the trade that is attacking
the king and the Queen so Queen captures
and the pawn recaptures there's a lot
that goes into this move as well because
this was forced could have easily if we
come back said yes I is whites I want to
go ahead and take here on f5 pawn has to
recapture so he looks at this position
says okay I have this option a and
option B is what he did plate Queen up
here to e6
force his opponent to take okay now
white no longer has an isolated pawn so
that's good he keeps this
on/off of the dark squares so you always
want to be looking at your opponent's
minor pieces in this case his opponents
Bishop is on a dark square so it can
never attack this pawn here unless this
pawn moves that's a good thing he no
longer has the absolutely pawns we
talked about he also gives his opponent
an isolated pawn here on the e-file the
issue that White has to deal with is the
fact that this pawn wall it's not
isolated because this pawn can come up
here and support it it's really far up
here on the sixth rank it's gonna be
very difficult for him to get material
here to try to protect that he can
always swing his rook over here to e1
but then that rook is just really
playing defense
once it a little more aggressive in the
game from black standpoint he just wants
to make it very very difficult for white
to hold on to this so that later on he
can have a strong attack on this pawn
you can see there's a lot of clutter on
the King side the board wall white does
have a dominant position from pawn
standpoint it's gonna be very difficult
to increase that advantage where on the
Queen side black definitely has the
advantage he has two pawns to one if
there could be some sort of exchange he
would have his own pond over here if
that would be a passed pawn definitely
would look to push that action here on
the Queen side of the board pawn to g5
attacking the bishop bishop comes back
here King to a g7 pawn appear to f4 rook
to d8 just centralized in that rook we
talked about wasn't really involved into
the action this bishop here on f6 for
awhile it's gonna act just like a pawn
it's not really gonna be moving too much
and it's just holding down this pawn
chain right here not much that I can do
about it either pawn to a4 pawn here to
h6 just solidifying the punch hand a
little bit now the Kings start to get
involved once the Queen comes off the
board you do start to see both sides get
their King involved into the game a
little bit more than they usually would
the rooks do exchange on a c1 rook to
the 5 just centralizing a little bit
King to f3 rook over here a5 starting to
attack says yeah I wanna I have two
palms over here this is my strategy I
can't overwhelm you on the King side so
I'm gonna go ahead and start attacking
on the
queenside rook to see for Bishop e5 just
centralising king up here to e4 and this
is a position where if you just look at
it real quick you may think now go ahead
and play Bishop takes on h2 that's why
you initially bring your Bishop here to
e5 to attack this pawn if you can just
get up one pawn that may be good enough
to win but this would be very bad this
is a poison pawn if you take this pawn
here on h2 a bad things start to happen
Bishop to d4 check maybe King to g6 a
lot of different options you could come
down and then rip to c8 preparing for
the work to come over here and check the
opponent's there's no real good way to
continue probably just start gobbling
out material here rook to a4 makes the
most sense best move for sure it does
pin down the bishop so the bishops not
gonna be getting out of line but rook
over here GA check maybe King to h7
Barilla doesn't matter where the King
goes there is going to be a check here
the King can't come to either of these
squares right here because of the pawn
can't come here because of the bishop so
King age 7 check after the rook now the
rook can move there's a discovered
attack takes the pawn here maybe the
rook takes here there's just no good way
to continue in the spot so at the end of
day this would be extremely bad if black
decides to take that pawn here on h2 he
analyzes the position realizes yeah
that's not the way to go anyplace King
to f6 so now the king is can fill in
that gap here on f6 definitely much
stronger move Bishop down here to d2
attacking the rook on a5 and then we see
the pawn to b5 says yeah if you want to
go ahead and take my rook that's fine I
will recapture your rook and I'll have a
passed pawn here I can easily push it
down here to c3 start to have very
strong attack since a ham up Bishop here
on e5 if you want to move all your
material here then black can start
gobbling up pawns here with this King so
a very strong attack here I decided to
go and take with this pawn instead but
then you can see after the road takes
b5 this is exactly what Shakir is
looking to do now he has that pass pawn
on the Queen side and it's right over
here on the Queen's outer one good thing
the white does have going for him is
Daniel has the dark squared bishop so
this is going to promote to a dark
square you always want to have a minor
piece that can protect the final square
right here so that's exactly what he
does have but he still has to be careful
this is a passed pawn that is gonna
require a lot of energy because black
has the same thing dark square bishop
that can control the square that it also
promotes too now we see rook to a4
bishop up here to be a truck a 1 and you
start to see some maneuvering around the
board and at the end of the day all
black really wants to do is get into a
position where he feels confident that
he's not gonna lose the King side of the
board and then he can freely push
forward with his pawn here he can't do
that right away
he can't move this Bishop as soon as he
moves his bishop this pawn is gonna fall
he would like to eventually move his
pawn here to a5 but right now he has to
worry about both the rook and the bishop
here on d2 so that's what both sides are
gonna be thinking about you know white
really can't put too much emphasis on
the King side because as soon as he does
this pawns gonna start pushing forward
so it's a game of cat-and-mouse here as
far as how both sides are maneuvering
into the endgame but black definitely
looks like he has the upper hand right
here we do see an exchange on the King
side rook comes over here to h1 to
attack rook to e5 check rook to the 5
check maneuver around into the game
rook eventually takes here and then we
see the exchange like it's still up at
that pawn right here it all is gonna
come down to can black actually execute
to the win it's not an easy position at
all we're 41 moves into the game so they
do have some extra time on the clock to
start thinking which is good because
it's a very complicated in game rook to
a4 attacking the pawn Bishop to c5 so a
little more centralized definitely
better than the bishop up here on b8
protecting it but still wants to find a
way that he can bring that pawn down
here to a5 pawn f3 Bishop to a b6
Bishop c3 King to d7 so just trying to
get the King involved into the game a
little bit more because it looks like
it's gonna be take all of the material
on the board to start pushing that pawn
here on the Queen side of the board so
you can see that we are going through
quite a few moves as both sides are just
maneuvering back and forth we do have a
few two-fold repetitions every now and
then and then eventually you will see a
pawn move and then they decide yeah I
don't want to draw here go into some
extra games let's see if we can actually
play this thing out play continues with
King to d2 a King c4 rook over here to
see one King d5 and then we start to see
an attack on this pawn here on f4 so
rook to e8 rook up here to h6 just
protecting the pond that the new rook is
attacking King here to F excuse me c3
and that's the opening once the King
moves here Bishop down here to III the
king the bishop are now attacking that
then rook to a8 I think a much better
approach to defend this would be rook to
e7 wants to attack it sure but also
wants to make sure that if the rook
comes down here to h4 which would be an
extremely strong move that he can still
protect things if he wants to you just
take this pawn here on e6 but because he
plays rook to e8 he doesn't have that
flexibility now black going to the in
game they played so many moves just
maneuvering around ended up deciding not
to play rook to h4 but continued with
rook to e8 here rook c1 could have also
started to take material here maybe
Bishop takes on f4 could get interesting
we see an exchange here the rook takes
and then he has to analyze this and say
can I win this game
I guess he decided
he could not so decided dish instead
play work to see one check now rook to
see six work up here to f8 now check
some more checks on the board rook to b6
some twofold repetition here King to c4
and finally 35 moves after we were
waiting figuring out how or when black
would fill he could eventually move his
pawn here he does pawn to e5 and so it
is game on now can black just continue
to push his pawn down at the board here
rook to a8 rook here to c6 check and
then the bishop takes the pawn here on
f4 now this is a tricky one because the
bishop can't really take here the King
takes and then yeah you have this pawn
here in the center of the board that's
gonna be easier to push than this pawn
here because the King is right next to
it the rook and the King both protecting
it you just can't stop that at all
so realizes this and plays Bishop down
here to c3 he's really just trying to
hold on now knowing that he can't win
this game he's down to pawns both of
those are just gonna be pushing as much
as possible we now see the bishop come
up here to c7 defending that pawn rook
the c8 and now we see the move to end
things and that is a4 with the
deflection there's just no real good way
to combat this if we see the King take
here on a4 then the rook takes on c3
still protecting the bishop here on c7
still has the passed pawn here on ace on
e6 sewn over way to continue we do see
King to see tube and then after King to
e3 we do see Daniel resign in the game
so Shakir to my Medina with the victory
he does win the round they did tie in
the first game and so as we've talked
about this is a best of two series you
win in that second game after the draw
and you will go on so
a lot of the players are going to be
playing tomorrow in the tiebreakers MDL
who won yesterday he did draw today so
he and Shakira the only two players
moving on already to the next round so
we will have her coverage tomorrow of
some of the tiebreak games and see who's
going to be moving on with those two
players we just mentioned on to round 2
hopefully you guys are enjoying this
tournament a lot of coverage that we're
gonna be having but thank you guys so
much for watching I'll see you guys in
the next video